- Good morning believe nation,
today's message is turn
your no's into how can I's?
Over to you Lori Grenier.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- To me, an entrepreneur is somebody who
will do whatever it takes.
- [Female Interviewer] Right.
- They're driven, they are
"A-type" personalities,
it's like they don't know the word no.
And that's always been my mantra,
I know no no's, just how can I?
So when I see that person
I know that no matter what,
even if they have to pivot,
you know, which is something that happens,
maybe this isn't the best idea
but something else is and
you're going to change it,
they're still going to make it
because they have what it takes
to be a successful entrepreneur.
- So I don't necessarily agree
that every entrepreneur needs
to be a type A personality
but you do need to be resourceful.
I think it's one of the
most consistent things
about entrepreneurship,
is you have to learn to be resourceful.
You're going to get a
lot of no's, expect it.
There's this great clip
of Sylvester Stallone,
where he says that he loves the word no,
because it means yes.
(laughing)
- Challenge, I really just I just love it.
You know, I love being told no.
It just means yes.
- I lot of people are afraid of no's,
a lot of people are afraid of rejection
and for that reason, a lot
of people have great ideas
can do amazing things,
you've got this genius thing inside you
that never gets out there
because you got one no.
A lot of people turn
into the person who then
because they got their one no
and they never took that bet on themselves
and they had to pull everyone
else down around them.
And so what I want you
to do is fast forward
to the end of your life,
think about where you're at
and think about you not
executing this idea.
Think about you having
not taken the action
that you want to take.
And what that feels like
to have how many years and years and years
and years and years and
years and years and years
of regret not having done the thing
that you're supposed to
do and is it worth it?
Whenever I'm afraid,
whenever I get a no,
whenever I feel down,
that's what I try to do.
If I continue to live thinking like this
imagine what I'm going to be
when I'm 150 lookin' back on my life
wishing that I had taken one more shot.
Wishing I'd done a little
little little tiny bit more.
So expect no's, embrace the no's,
don't be defeated by the no's.
Get excited by a no.
Cuz after the no, if you do it again,
and you do it again, and you do it again,
eventually you're going to get the yes
that you deserve.
So the question today is I'm curious,
what is the most resourceful thing
you've ever had to do in your business?
Leave it in the comments below,
I'm curious to find out.
Also want to give a quick
shout out to Gregory Gomes,
Gregory thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word, really
means a lot to me man,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
Thank you guys so much for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is,
much love and I'll see
ya again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- Well I've launched in the last 16 years
400 new products,
and I have 115 patents.
- People going through this
now have a lot of options,
you have fundraising
sites like Kickstarter,
you have little online
marketplaces like Etsy.
Do you recommend that people use these
to sort of test out their products?
- I think a lot of people
don't trust their gut enough.
I think a lot of people want
somebody to hold their hand
through the process.
And really that's not the best way.
There's no special formula that's right
for every single person.
You have to decide do
you like Kickstarter,
do you feel that's right for you?
Or you know, people have other ways
in which to do things.
So I think it's know your options.
- It's true that I'm a woman in business,
so are you and it's great
because they are different personalities,
successful, be yourself,
take care of business.
- Be yourself.
- Go for it, get out there.
- Yes.
- But it can be bumpy along the way.
Any regrets or mistakes
that you feel you've
kind of hit through the years?
- Well you know, I share
certain bumps that I've had
in the book.
I think that, you know I
don't like to look back,
there are no mistakes really,
everything is a learning lesson,
everything helps you to do better.
- [Queen Latifah] Right
- So I talk about some of
the mistakes that I made
and it just helps you
to get further along,
learn from those mistakes
and get smarter.
True feeling is this,
no matter who you are,
no matter what age you are,
no matter the time in your life,
if you have a dream,
and you have the drive,
you can make anything happen.
And if you are ever feeling down
or feeling like you
can't get over that hump,
or you just have a bad day,
I play this song, and you
remember this song okay?
Here it goes.
♫ This girl is on fire
(audience applause)